don't worry don't worry it's gonna go so
smooth this ain't gonna be like the
tolkien thing
i'm fine i'm good it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine
hello hey brando sando how you doing
today baby
i'm just sitting here with some news is
it a white sands adaptation
what no no no god no um no no we got the
first stormlight episodes back from
netflix and they are looking
good oh wonderful of course it's
wonderful your books are flying off the
shelves like a high storm through middle
earth baby oh that's not
did you read the books i skimmed the
wiki look this means new covers
i love the original covers michael
wieland did such an amazing job not to
mention the whole graphic design
team however some people complain that
my name is so much bigger than the
titles
are we gonna fix that the title are you
kidding me that's what spines
are for look just consider this your
name
taking up three-fourths of the front the
title and the mass market
consider it a need-to-know basis will
anyone see the cover art because each
cover has one of those beautiful oil
paintings meticulously crafted by one of
the highest skilled artists in the field
brandon i'm gonna stop
you there look you're overthinking this
we have greg and he's one of the best
screenshotters in the business
did you just say screenshotter you find
anything greg
hold on hold on
got it and brandon here's the real
money maker okay you ready for this
buckle in your little seat belt you
safety oriented little bug
we're going to take a sticker it's a
paper sticker you can't peel it off and
we're going to put it in the top
right corner that's right we're just
gonna
put that right there you try and peel it
i mean what about the trade paperbacks
are they gonna be any different
book one you know how fans are crazy
over that dal in our casting dave
batista is
killing it so we're gonna put him right
there it's gonna be iconic
of course book two wide
wide wide wide wide have you seen adam
driver's shirt list we're gonna
thirst adele and fans so hard okay so
book three
over book three nick cage is just
absolutely slaying at a sill so we're
just gonna throw him on the cover right
there
who would have thought it's really
perfect casting yeah
and then for book four we're just gonna
take a screenshot of henry cavill in a
bathtub and we're just gonna
put him on there wait henry cavill was
cast no he has not been cast in the show
why would that be relevant
anyway but yeah those will be the images
associated with stormlight until the end
of time are readers supposed to like
this
better hell no brando you know better
this is not
for the fantasy fans all right this is
for the aunts
the uncles the well-meaning step parents
trying to buy a child's affection okay
they go into the barnes and noble
they see it's the show on the shelf and
they get it for the kids that's where
the big bucks are
guilt money i can still hear the
hesitation in your face
through the phone so what i want you to
do is go to your inbox
and just tell me what you see because
they're there yeah that's right we got
you the compass
it's blurry oh sorry greg did you
screenshot 480p again
sorry boss it's gotta be 720 hd
or better i'm sorry brendo we'll get you
the clearer ones
what was that what was that brit be
honest did you just finish another book
on the phone with me
no no
wait why are you using a typewriter my
hard drive ran out of space